hello everybody my name is marbl and
welcome to the world's quietest let's
play this game is called don't
scream so I've calibrated my
microphone so that if my voice
goes so if my voice goes above this line
or if Henry or chica bark outside I'll
probably lose the
game and that's how the game is supposed
to go just don't scream so that's
exactly what I'm going to be doing I
think I have a calibrated
properly I don't know why I feel they
need to lean into the microphone to talk
cuz that just puts me more at risk but
I'm going to try to play this and not
scream what I don't know is if the
game what I don't know
is if the game will end and quit
forever or if I simply
restart that doesn't seem
good you all right
why is the timer counting down when I'm
moving I really hope I don't have to
sneeze I imagine that some people would
try to play this and simply not talk at
all but where's the fun in that
also what am I looking
at airplane Parts oh there's literally
an airplane over there what am I seeing
swinging
well seems like an alternative start to
the
forest it's not
good also I'm pretty sure that planes
don't don't have vending
machines but what do I really
[Music]
know so far so good despite the
bodies swinging overhead
seems like they just lost the game I
have to adjust my
chair
I didn't do
anything this my stupid haunted
light really likes to turn off in random
times
and there it is again all is well all
will always be
well and I
especially will be
well
slightly
unusual there you have
it siren
[Music]
head
I don't know if that's supposed to be
the black box of the cockpit or
something but
that's
but that's not what those look like got
dark real
quick not sure what that's
about
oh that is awfully
convenient you know clearly if the
people on the plane didn't
scream none of this would have
happened
I don't know if someone set this up here
for my
convenience but
I Henry better not lose this for me
anyway I don't know if that was set up
for my convenience but
I but I appreciate the
gesture didn't need the flashlight
anyway
it's like a built-in Shake we recharging
system I'm going to assume that's
blood but really what do we
know I thought I was going the right way
to get in
here I
was let's do a quick reality check
here we crash land in the middle of a
forest bodies swinging
people screaming not
me and then there's a mini
mart it's probably
[Music]
real ordinarily this is where I would be
shouting as I enter hello it's me marbl
but alas I can't give them
[Music]
that you're
naked you're
naked that chicken's
naked pardon
me that's fine
[Music]
all
well that was fun
I was about to say
hello well that's not
sanitary technically that's not supposed
to be
sanitary
do I get
[Music]
a was I supposed to get
something
was that the sound of the Rolling door
in the
back I don't know what that
was
[Music]
I don't know what any of that is
supposed to be but certainly it is not
for me was I supposed to find
something
there's something up
there it's the only thing I can
tell I don't know what that
was ordinarily I would
be
ordinarily I would be sprinting Into the
Woods at top speed but something tells
me the trepidation might be the correct
Course once again you usually don't find
a vending machine in a place such as
this
whoever that was you lose the game that
way
[Music]
the rules apply for everyone even
babies that baby
lost
I don't know where I'm
going I don't really have a
landmark it's going to take more than
that I've been playing horror games for
a very long
time I have the thickest girth skin you
could Poss possibly
imagine run
away even crows can
lose
oh
maybe I'm the scary one that lip smack
almost lost me the
game what was that
don't they know the
rules okay
goodbye come
back
I'm hearing what might be om and his
music unsure if that's a good
thing another
loser it's Forest is full of
losers
[Music]
well that's
unsettling help
help
at least you weren't
naked it is just mirror do the trees
look like they're
shivering I'm
sorry what occurred
my question is are you just going to
keep throwing the same things at
me
[Music]
nerd I thought they were
dead
hello
oh I have a strange feeling that was my
fault grandma just had to
go
I'm sensing
something I was right I did sense
[Music]
something
I'm beginning to
understand that this is the Battle
Royale of horror
games and I am the
scariest of all
[Music]
E I suppose if I were to vomit all over
my microphone that would also count as a
loss but for
now I
remain didn't even could see that coming
[Applause]
they're really trying
now they're trying very
hard
[Applause]
[Music]
help is this a
cliff would be amazing if I ended this
because I took fall
damage
I suppose if I laugh that would also
[Applause]
be
what a lovely false sense of
security is this also a false sense of
security not bad I want to see what
happens if I lose
[Music]
La
huh
h
[Music]
Hello bye-bye